foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter Theory today we're going to be
discussing Albus Dumbledore and his
cursed hand more specifically we're
going to be breaking down Dumbledore's
death the curse itself and one scenario
in which maybe just maybe Dumbledore
could have saved himself let's get into
it months before Dumbledore's tragic
demise Dumbledore himself had decided to
track down one of Voldemort's horcruxes
a small ring crowned with a strange dark
stone and what made this particular
horcrux unique is that this Stone was in
fact one of the fabled Deathly Hallows
the resurrection Stone to be precise the
history of the stone dates back some
time with its origin story suggesting
that it had been given to the Middle
Brother Cadmus peverel by death himself
then the second brother who was an
arrogant man decided that he wanted to
humiliate death still further and ask
for the the power to recall others from
death so death picked up a stone from
the riverbank and gave it to the second
brother and told him that the stone
would have the power to bring back the
dead as mentioned above this Stone had
the power to summon Spirits back from
the dead but when Voldemort stole his
uncle morphin's ring years and years
prior he had no idea that it contained
such a powerful Relic to him it was just
a family heirloom and more importantly
an item that he could taint with dark
magic an item he could turn into a
horcrux but when Albus first found the
stone and noticed its distinct markings
he immediately realized that it was one
of the three Deathly Hallows knowing the
true power of the stone Dumbledore's
curiosity got the better of him and he
ended up placing the ring on his finger
securing his fate in the end it was the
Allure of the Resurrection stone that
had prompted Dumbledore to slide the
ring onto his finger and receive
Voldemort's lethal curse why did he do
it well to Dumbledore the stone
represented one last chance at seeing
his sister Ariana who tragically died
decades and decades prior did Dumbledore
know that the ring was the hall cracks
yes but the Allure of the stone caused a
momentary lapse in his judgment
resulting in him being Afflicted with a
lethal curse just like all the
Voldemort's horcruxas he had protected
it with dark magic and to this
particular horcrux would curse anyone
who tried the ring on when I discovered
it after all those years buried in the
abandoned home of the gaunts the Hallow
had craved most of all though in my
youth I'd wanted it for very different
reasons I lost my head Harry I quite
forgot that it was now a horcrux that
the ring was sure to carry a curse I
picked it up and I put it on and for a
second I imagined that I was about to
see Mariana and my mother and my father
and to tell them how very very sorry I
was
and immediately after placing the cursed
ring on his finger Dumbledore realizes
that his clock is ticking his time is
running out fortunately thanks to Snape
and his expertise in curses and Potions
Dumbledore was able to buy some time but
he still didn't have much of it he knew
that ultimately the curse would kill him
with Snape's help the curse was confined
to a single hand grinding the Headmaster
some extra time alive however I think
that it's important to remember that had
Dumbledore been a lesser wizard The
Curse would have stopped his heart on
the spot because of the way that
Dumbledore was able to handle his
Affliction many interpreted this curse
to be some sort of slow acting killing
charm but this is not the case it took
every bit of Dumbledore's strength and
Snape's experience to Halt the
progression of the curse and in this
respect Dumbledore was very very lucky
my question is this if Dumbledore's
curse had been effectively confined to a
single hand why not just chop it off
Snape said it himself that the curse had
been temporarily contained the main
concern surrounding Dumbledore's
survival was that the curse would
eventually spread further to me chopping
it off seems like the logical solution
here I've got a couple of things to say
about this Dumbledore would have lost a
hand I'm sure but that would have been a
small price to pay for survival if we
think back on the series then one
character comes to mind who chops off
his hand for Less much less wormtel was
whimpering he pulled a long thin shining
silver Dagger from inside his cloak his
voice broke into petrified sobs flesh of
the servant willingly given you will
revive your master he stretched his
right hand out in front of him the hand
with the missing finger he gripped the
dagger very tightly in his left hand and
swung it upward Harry realized what
wormtail was about to do a second before
it happened he closed his eyes as
tightly as he could but he could not
block the scream that pierced the Knight
that went through Harry as though he had
been stabbed with the dagger too
here's the thing the curse was
completely Uncharted Territory even for
Dumbledore and Snape neither of them had
ever dealt with a curse like that yes I
suppose they could have cut Dumbledore's
hand off after confining the curse but
who's to say that the curse was really
confined
what if they cut his hand off only to
realize that the curse then transferred
itself to the rest of his body what if
this type of curse clings on to the
living entity of the victim until they
die until they've let out every last
breath then Dumbledore would be cursed
and handless there's also the
possibility that cutting off his hand
would have killed him sooner with no
hand Snape's preventative measures would
no longer be in place and it's entirely
possible the curse would have
immediately killed him what if this
previously contained curse suddenly now
affected all of Dumbledore well all of
that is possible but I suppose the only
options for Dumbledore at this stage
were die slowly or cut off the hand and
see what happens but let's pretend for a
second that cutting off the hand was a
Surefire way of keeping Dumbledore alive
in this case why not do it unsure of
what might happen I can imagine both
Snape's and Dumbledore's reluctance on
the matter Snape would have to butcher
someone and act I'm sure he'd find
repulsive and Dumbledore would run the
risk of either dying right away or being
more helpless for his final days while
remaining cursed Dumbledore was used to
being well Dumbledore and being a less
powerful version of himself can't have
been too inviting a prospect for the
most powerful wizard of all time now
let's suppose that cutting off the hand
would work and both Snape and Dumbledore
knew it would work there's still one
problem Malfoy in the Half Blood Prince
Snape enters into an unbreakable vow
where he agrees to protect Draco help
him with his task of killing Dumbledore
and even finish it himself should Draco
fail draco's mission to kill Dumbledore
was given to him by Voldemort himself
and I'm sure the Dumbledore knew that if
Draco were to fail in this Mission then
he would be punished severely by
Voldemort at the end of the day
Dumbledore had a plan in motion that
accounted for his death and on a
personal level he was simply ready to
embrace death
I know that Dumbledore placing the ring
on his finger has often been interpreted
as a foolish impulsive decision made out
of desperation but what we have to
remember here is that this is Dumbledore
a beacon of wisdom more likely is this
when Dumbledore saw the resurrection
Stone set in the ring as a horcrux he
began to lament at how much of a selfish
fool he had been in his youth then in a
moment blaring of poetic justice he
chose to put the cursed ring on so that
he could join his family in the
afterlife and find forgiveness in death
Dumbledore had lived too long without
love and it was his time to move on do
not pity the dead Harry pity the living
and above all those who live without
love and that's it for this video did
you ever ask yourself these questions
let me know down in the comment section
below if you enjoy the content please
like the video and subscribe to the
channel until next time remember to the
well-organized Mind death is but the
next great adventure